the one thing I would have an immediate
bias was was towards the Middle East
I identify as
trans gender nonconforming it's not
often assumed that I'm part black do you
think that being gay is a choice I can't
be sure who should police the police the
citizens that actually scares me if I
had to have a conversation with my kids
about this we'd know pretty much where
to start how I treat and talk to my
children is very much reflective of the
environment that they walk into every
day I'm a lawyer by trade so I gotta
watch what I say I've been a cop for 20
years we must understand that how we've
been weaponized you know against the
black community hello everybody my name
is Jesse Williams I want to welcome
everyone joining us today as we discuss
bias conscious and unconscious bias and
its impact on us personally and the
collective I am here now because I feel
like we're experiencing the real
opportunity the real opportunity is in
the public consciousness with all that's
happening in the world and in our nation
we are primed I think to accept the
possibility that maybe we have some room
for improvement maybe there are some
things that we can learn about ourselves
in each other that will allow us to grow
forward so part of that is acknowledging
conscious and unconscious bias the roles
that we might be playing in this whole
equation I think it's really incredibly
important for us to face it talk about
it be open to that possibility
everyone has biased myself included it
is a real issue and and it's something
that we can address and just learn more
about it doesn't make anybody in here at
me wrong it's something that's worthy of
exploring so over the over the next few
hours we're gonna do just that we're
gonna watch a series of conversations
between complete strangers meeting for
the first time and they're gonna discuss
not only themselves but issues that
bring up the concept of bias in their
lives this might be uncomfortable at
times it certainly has moments of
discomfort for them and might for you as
well feelings could be hurt but that's
part of the process
how growth happens so admits amidst that
discomfort these are all opportunities
for learning for us so before we dive
deeper I do want to acknowledge how we
always come here today that can do that
without thinking Procter and Gamble for
spreading the word and spearheading this
effort that also includes BuzzFeed who's
allowing us to use their platform so
thank you so much for years P&G has been
using their voice and acting as a
leading advertiser to shine a light on
inequality highlighting bias in
particular with their recent work in the
last couple years and sparking a
dialogue to promote understanding to
promote action so I'm not gonna do this
alone we are going to dial up the
incredible Freddy ransom who is a
content creator has a lot of insight
around bias and she's gonna help us walk
through this whole experience and be a
great asset to us today hey Jessie how
are you I'm great how are you I'm good
I'm excited for what today is gonna hold
um just to you know give everyone a
little bit more detail about the ins and
outs of this experiment we have paired
14 strangers together to talk about bias
and these are real people they are here
because they want to have dialogue and
they want to experience a personal
growth so please be respectful to them
in the comments even if you don't agree
on what they're saying because we're all
friends here we're all just here to
learn and take in new information or
just sort of spread light and share
light to each other in regards to
experiences and personal biases it's
interesting and when talking to new
people are strangers I think folks can
relate to being at a party or new
gathering you just find yourself kind of
pouring your heart out to somebody you
just met I think the idea that won't
definitely follow you in your social
circle or your family event you've got a
little bit of freedom to just kind of
unload something to explore something
experiment play around with ideas
without it being kind of attached to you
like the static cling and you're gonna
have to be accountable for it later
we all carry with us learned assumptions
presumptions we all are a byproduct of
media and marketing and information and
cartoons and commercials also now's a
good time just to let folk
know where it's not only Freddie and
myself participating today we are really
lucky to have an absolutely brilliant
professor dr. Charisse slippery sharing
her credible talents and wherewithal
professor the Prix is at Syracuse
University where she currently focuses
on how the media affects the way we
think about ourselves exactly what we're
talking about our perceptions of
ourselves and others we've been working
with her to bring an added layer of
context
and facts into this discussion those
pesky things that are necessary beyond
just watching we're gonna be posting
discussion prompts in the comments so
pay attention to those if you could this
allows us all to be able to join the
conversation from an informed
perspective so be sure to add your
thoughts and questions there as well
this is a safe space so please don't
succumb to any habits so you know we've
all been in comment sections and we can
see how I can get a child that showed me
quickly let's elevate today let's make
that a safe space if you have
constructive conversations and now while
we have paired strangers together
they're not entirely random we
intentionally went about this in a
curated fashion to encourage discourse
beyond their echo chamber these has been
a really expansive long conversations
when we've paired these strangers
together
so we've naturally had to edit them down
for time we do that in the most
responsible way so in order to catalyze
these conversations we have passed along
P and G's award-winning short film
called the look to all of these pairings
so they can watch it together and it can
be a great way to spark conversation
about bias
let's start with our first pairing we
have chose e joining us from Atlanta
Georgia
and we have Lynn in North Carolina so we
have them dialed up and meeting each
other for the very first time for an
interesting conversation all right let's
do it
hello hi how you doing well I'm well
today and yourself I'm doing great I'm
just excited about this experience isn't
as something my name is Lynn Lynn Lynn
hi my name is Josie
oh come on
[Music]
I can definitely relate to the beginning
getting the word looks for looking
different I can't believe this stuff
still happens and I know it does and I
cannot understand why yeah we we so
judge each other on the way we
immediately appear where do you think
that comes from the reason I think a lot
of people think that way which is not
only in the u.s. it's a global thing
it's just Laco interaction with people
that are different than you
I am origionally from East Jerusalem
Palestine and I came here in 2001 three
weeks before September 11 so when I came
here I was saying a Middle Eastern on
Palestinian Muslim and he's just who I
am I'm gonna think anything of it so
September 11 happens and there all of a
sudden there's this hate for anybody
that looks Middle Eastern so if you're
brown you're gonna be a target it
doesn't matter if you're Arab Indian
Hispanic mixed black and white just dark
featured and a lot of people got
harassed and attacked on campus Georgia
Southern and I was like I'm not gonna go
out and say that I'm Middle Eastern I'm
gonna have to dodge it fly it try to be
a chameleon but it's hard to be a
chameleon when the majority is black and
white nobody looks like me what I'm
hearing you say is that it comes from
non exposure to different types of
people and they're visually different
and we have to judge immediately the one
kind of group that you can see my
ignorance I think when I thought about
biases towards people the one thing I
would have an immediate bias was was
towards whatever I would call and you're
right it's ignorant the Middle East
because it's there
friend and so as we've had more
immigrants and as I've been able to meet
more people you see my views change and
this is the only way that we can break
down these conclusions it's kind of
embarrassing here to admit that I've had
these these biases it's embarrassing but
I have not really been able to interact
very much with people like yourself
Josie so I don't know how the universe
know that that you're the person I
probably needed to talk most to yeah
I've been in churches here when I came
to the u.s. and I've been to Baptist
churches and I'm looking around and I
see this poster of a white person that
looks like Kurt Cobain's from Nirvana
with blond hair blue eyes on a cross and
I'm like who is that and he's like this
is Jesus and I'm like what Jesus from
Bethlehem Jesus was a a Jewish person
from Bethlehem in Palestine if you go to
Palestine right now nobody's blonde blue
hair blue eyes I'm considered
light-skinned people are a little bit
darker than you I don't care what the
census says that we are I'm not cheated
like I'm a white person when I come to
America I'm accepted by blacks more than
whites where I grew up in Northern
California there was a lot of dissension
with black people we didn't even have
anybody from Palestine or Jerusalem like
we didn't have Jewish people and I drove
through the part of town that was black
and because I was white they threw a
rock at me because they were angry and
that was when integration was starting
and they would bring black people and
white white black children and white
people and white children together were
people and we're doing the best we can
and it's not real good but if we keep
talking about it meeting each other and
if I can see your pain and maybe you can
see my embarrassment
because that's just who I am and I'm
still trying to change let me let you
picture this four hundred years ago
you've been brought to this country in
shackles enslaved let's say they traded
your people for money they gave you
freedom but everything you ever built
they will burn and they always will make
you feel like you're the bad person so
no matter what you do and how high you
get in life you will still be that slave
how would you feel would you throw a
brick at somebody I would probably try
to burn everything down because it's so
unfair it's so unfair I really honestly
feel if I had been at the scene when
George Floyd was being killed because
I'm a little white woman I probably
could have jumped in there and they
would have been busy because I'm not a
threat it's cold why you don't see me
the police don't see me as a threat
I've been pulled over and let go and
they they've said to me if you were
black I'd take you in but you're not how
do we change this Josie how do we do
this people need to be aware of their
white privilege during 9/11 I was
walking back to my dorm I don't know
what's going on I've been in America for
three weeks I walk in I'm looking at the
big TV in the lobby I see a building on
fire people jumping and chaos and I'm
like oh this looks like back home why
because we see this every day this is
nothing new so from that day on middle
Easterns and Muslims has suffered ten
times more till this day and they're
being they burned mosques they killed
Muslims they ban Muslims from coming to
this country well I thought this country
is based on freedom to worship any you
know to practice any religion I'm very
moved by your description of exactly how
you were treated Josie and the ignorance
that makes me
crying it makes me really embarrassed
but things are changing people are
people are moving all over and we need
to help people like you change it
actually changed against with people
like you that are thinking about these
issues but still not taking action the
smallest action you can take is number
one surround yourself with people that
are different than you number two talk
to people your family know how to talk
to them without having a constructive
conversation that can have criticism and
some defense in offense but we have to
unite the people we have to put our
differences on the side we can't just
keep bringing these biased and prejudice
and racist things that keeps dividing us
I'm so moved by what you said Josie and
I understand that the actions that I
take our heart to talk to be aware but
talk to people especially as I meet them
because I'm probably not at all what I
appear and I didn't tell the producers
that you know I'm gay and certainly I've
had beer bottles thrown at me
and I have not wanted to bother anybody
I just wanted to be left alone and be
myself whatever that is and I've
pretended a lot because I can get away
with pretending so you're with a woman
yes sir okay so you didn't mention that
song I'm glad you mentioned that because
well then you would have kana
experienced a lot more of what we
experienced I never really said too much
about it because I just felt like it's
nobody's business
and honestly I lied about it because it
could I mean you can't even you can't
see that I'm gay as I've grown and seen
the things that people have gone through
and the way that gay men were treated in
the eighties with the AIDS epidemic and
losing so many people that were my
friends and no one cared it does make
sense that if I had
he stood up and cop-tur the whole thing
and made a stand and said no you don't
treat people this way because these
people are me and if you like me then
you like gay people right but here in
Hendersonville North Carolina I've been
actually legally married and and that is
an ex form of acceptance and I have
nephews and nieces who have grown up and
they don't think a thing about this
because of their exposure to people that
were gay and they go well so what's
what's the big deal come on I thank you
for sharing that with me because that's
part of who you are there's no way to
see that or tell that so that was pretty
interesting twist and it kind of changed
the whole aspect of this call because I
knew then I can definitely relate and
make you relate mostly to what I've been
feeling and have empathy as well for
what you've been going through and I
know this trouble because I'm from the
Middle East were not open for for that
and my cousin is gay he says he tries to
make a noise about it so he can get the
equality and the freedom I want you to
do the same so I had this epiphany while
you were talking that this is how bias
changes is that you've had this
conversation with me and maybe you'll be
with somebody or or your family in one
way and and they'll talk about something
but you've had this experience you'll
you'll go well you know there was this
time I talked to this woman and and
believe me if n I see anybody from
Palestine it's gonna be well you know I
talked to this man and he was from
Palestine and he's in this country and
this is how he feels I want to thank you
and for doing this and I want to also
thank you for
sharing with me and being able to listen
and respond and have a very healthy
conversation thank you well Josie I
think the best part about talking to you
well I'm sitting here realizing that oh
I just came out to the entire world and
I did that because of you and because of
what you and the people that produced
you have been through and you made me
understand the pain and you've helped me
really immeasurably look at all the
things I said I owe that to you sir I do
how about that go figure thank you thank
you thank you
[Music]
okay so that was chose Ian Lin really
you know little plot twist towards the
end I know for me personally when I was
watching the video I was not expecting
her to say that she was a part of the
queer community and that she's married
and has this whole other part to her
story that we were at least I was
unaware of at the beginning so that was
kind of interesting and I think also you
know kind of in real-time this bias is
sort of playing out it's like I'm
thinking like oh yeah she's you know sis
heterosexual white woman who like you
know probably hasn't really experienced
a lot of turmoil in terms of identity
and that's just me you know making that
assumption and then to find out that oh
actually she has experienced this you
know okay
now I'm sort of getting a better
understanding of who she is yeah what
was interesting to me was how it
impacted Josie immediately it always
makes folks feel more comfortable having
conversations with people who can or are
willing to understand them whatever that
means and a big part of that is a shared
actual experience parents talking about
how hard it is to have children they can
relate to actual parents much better
than some single person with no kids
right and that's it's it's it's really
that basic so when Rosie thinks he's
talking to somebody who kind of fits all
the dominant boxes
most of them outside of gender to hear
oh well you actually have to deal with
identity with making yourself small with
making yourself quiet but not always
identifying yourself in a way that would
make you a target okay we're actually on
closer footing than I thought that makes
me see you slightly different or maybe
feel more comfortable expressing my
experience in a way that has a better
shot of being received I think you
watched Lynne certainly for lack of a
better term kind of mature and grow and
settle into her comfort zone yeah he
loved to see that and I can say too like
I was really happy that Lynne was self
aware in the facts and you know
confident in sort of admitting that she
lied about her sexuality for you
because she knew that she could you know
she could sort of slider to the radar as
outwardly I guess presenting as you know
a straight white woman you know walking
through the world and that was that was
interesting because I think that that
sort of transcends in so many different
scenarios whether you can you know pass
race wise or ethnically nor in terms of
religion sexuality I think that we all
could come with or come to the table
with certain areas where we can pass and
we sort of use that for survive survival
yeah I don't necessarily think that it's
that she's ashamed but a lot of times
it's about safety so that's something
that stood out to me
a couple things that I clocked not
because they were new but actually
because they're fairly common and my
lived experience is what bias can do is
it can minimize or isolate the
experiences of others while chowsie
explains some of his experience and the
discrimination that he goes through I
mean can you imagine being Palestinian
landing here three weeks before 9/11 in
Atlanta Georgia the fear that yes just
how do you go out and get coffee every
day you're going out he could possibly
be
we saw hate crimes obviously skyrocket
and as he describes some of this you see
what I've seen commonly I imagine you
have as well Freddie is is kind of
incredulous nest from your white
acquaintance I had I had no idea
totally either blind or reflexively
presenting themselves as blind to lived
experiences of of those around us oh no
way can you believe it I had no idea
something like this would happen
and so it's the combination of
distancing minimizing that experience
whether consciously or not and then
making the burden of solving it on the
person of color it's sort of the whole
idea that racism is an issue that the
marginalized community has to solve or
it's like a black issue or an Asian
issue or whichever community
and it is not it is a white issue you
know issue of the oppressor of those
with privilege and those in power yeah
all right so let's move on to our next
pairing and it's going to be JC and
garnet both of whom are currently based
in Arizona
hello hi hi my name is garnet I'm JC
hi JC I love your outfit thank you
where are you located I'm in Arizona
where you at oh that's where I'm
currently safer at home really yeah
[Music]
now we're getting stared at
[Music]
okay now as this individual I'm very
nervous that was that was scary
yeah we're in Korra are we the attorney
are the the judge are we the jury oh
please let it be the judge oh my god yes
what got me the most was the moment we
were in the courtroom my mind thought
okay they're bringing out the defendant
and it's his POV I was viscerally
relieved when that wasn't the case yeah
automatically I'm like oh my god I'm
nervous and I'm nervous because I hope
that this person isn't gonna get
prosecuted for incorrect reasons so I I
think I was trying to compensate with
like I hope he's the judge I hope he's
the attorney I hope he's the jury you
know so I could like also breathe a sigh
of relief from it as well
I think that I'm not immediately
identified by other people especially
people who are white it's not often
assumed that I'm part black it's just
assumed that I'm not white which is not
quite the same especially now for most
of my adult life I had a shaved head I
used to get extra security screenings
pat-downs taken out of line questioned
in the back room of no windows all the
time and I was basically being racially
profiled and it wasn't because I was
part black is because I looked Middle
Eastern and my mom said you need to
shave your hair but my first instinct
was like yeah that's a good idea and
then my next reaction was no that's the
opposite of what I want to do because
that would mean I would be taking one
more visibly at least part black
individual out of the situation and
that's exactly what people who hate
black people want to happen they just
want fewer black people around yes your
hair is political and I can relate to a
lot of what you were talking about I
also traveled a lot as a flight
attendant for the past six years okay
and I also was getting profiled a lot as
like Middle Eastern I've had pretty
serious altercation with one pilot in
the cockpit that was treating me really
hard
and they basically like were pinning me
to like the inside of the cockpit door
and it was just so so so scary to have
that and that's that's tough that's I'm
sorry to hear that I'm 25 percent black
I'm 75 percent life I'm not American I'm
actually Canadian but it wasn't until I
arrived here in the US that people
started to regularly recognize the black
part of me and mostly there were other
left people and so I started to you know
I I would go get my hair cut you know I
would always seek out like blackest
barber shop because whenever I walked
into a place like that there was never
like who's this beige guy you know let's
see about they automatically were like
yeah this guy's part black he's part of
this community
I identify as trans gender
non-conforming I basically wake up and
every single day is a little gender
reveal party to myself just like go with
the flow you know I feel like today I'm
like yeah I guess I'm feeling more
masculine I'm feeling more feminine so
but when I would go to work and have to
wear a uniform with the tie
I would purposefully like find like one
or two things to like express my gender
whether that was like the woman's purse
or something and like I would get
constantly like asked by co-workers like
is that really are you allowed to do
that
like they're not condoning us saying
anything to you not writing you letters
and I'm like I'm wearing a bag the same
bag you have so why like yeah and it was
really frustrating to like have to
constantly validate my gender or like
myself or even have to explain
especially to folks who didn't really
want to be educated about it they were
just sort of like projecting their own
views on to me that would be really
challenging definitely challenging I
mean I was in my early 20s then I had a
roommate and it was around that time
that I started to sort of come into
feeling out being art black and wanting
to embrace that part of myself because
up until then I hadn't I read Malcolm X
is that autobiography and I mean I even
went and saw Louis Farrakhan speak and
you know I was just exploring and he
kind of confronted me in a way that I
wasn't expecting and this is one of my
best friends he said
why are you reading that why are you
getting into all of this like black
stuff and I was like well you know I'm
I'm part black you know and he's like
well you're only 25% black so why don't
you just get over it and embrace the
majority of yourself which is white and
I was really angry because the fact is
is that you only have to be a little bit
non-white for people to see you is not
white and that can really for lack of a
better word color your experience in the
world exactly when you are in white
spaces and you talk about your blackness
how is that received that's a good
question
white people always want to ask what my
background is oh yeah same where are you
from I'm like oh well originally I'm
from Calgary where your parents from Oh
my dad's from the Calgary my mom's from
Manitoba do they know but where are they
really from and I'm like oh I see you're
wondering why I'm not lying because they
want to get to what race I am where do I
fit into their idea of who I should be
or what I represent I understand exactly
what you're saying was there ever a time
in your life when you found yourself
either suppressing a part of your
identity whatever that may be in order
to make a social situation or any
situation easier or more comfortable for
everyone in the room kind of thing I was
like 12 or 13 years old and I just
wanted to be a like a Manic Pixie dream
girl that like sits on countertops and
is cute and weird and I just wanted to
be that for myself right so I was
expressing like myself in that way and I
remember these men and my family pulled
me aside and they were you're acting
feminine and you need to like macho up
because you're turning into like a young
man and blah blah blah blah like that's
how that's the way it felt oh my god I'm
doing something wrong and this really
hurts my family and I'm being shameful
and that moment got internalized for
years like 10 14 whatever years even if
I'm trying to just change like my diet I
feel like I have to like
almost feel ashamed of like my lifestyle
as I explained it to my family and it
comes from just years and years of never
getting my needs met or being seen as
you know who I am
hmm yeah and this might strike you is I
don't know I don't know how you're gonna
take this but a time when I've
suppressed something about myself is I
like karaoke yes when I was in Toronto I
I was a karaoke host for a long time
full time and the best place that I
hosted that was this it was a gay bar
and yes when I worked there I found
myself in wordly embracing the fact that
maybe people thought I was gay because I
happened to be hosting a karaoke show in
a gay bar
and I was I was happy about that hey
this actually brings up an important
question that I think is relevant how do
we consume and appreciate and amplify
voices that need to be heard without
being appropriating and/or gaining
anything from it because as an ally
clearly I see you as an ally for LGBTQ
community especially working and hosting
in a gay bar and being super comfortable
in there but in what ways has your white
passing experience how has that showed
up for you I worked in a place that was
a very high-level private member's Club
I don't even think there were any black
members and I was witness to people
talking about things that were blatantly
racist like telling like n-word jokes
and stuff I'm standing right there and
I'm thinking to myself oh they don't
realize I'm part black and so at the
moment I just didn't say anything
because I didn't want to have that
confrontation in that environment I want
to just do a quick little example I had
from when I was a flight attendant and I
was in the back of the airplane and we
were in flight and all of a sudden I
heard some music or something happening
in the cabin and I instantly went to
this black couple to go ask them to turn
off their phones or their speakers or
whatever and when I went there they had
nothing and then
I was like excuse me and then they just
looked at me and they're like what's up
and I'm like oh my god I just did
something that was super biased it just
really showed me the bias that I had I
was so inappropriate jaesi let me ask
you a question why do you think bias is
dangerous
I don't think bias itself is necessarily
the danger it's not recognizing that you
have bias that is dangerous that
eventually trickles down to resentment
and then to hate and then to extreme
actions that are just inexcusable and
dangerous for so many folks do you think
that knowing that people have conscious
and unconscious biases do you think it's
possible for people to overcome them not
only do I think that it's possible for
people to overcome their biases I think
people's lives depend on it right now
people need to recognize their own bias
and how they can show up and fix those
biases for literally the survival of
black people they can no longer just
show up by posting pictures on Instagram
even walking in marches it's like do
this now because it's important right
now in history but do this from now on
and call it out when you see it and call
it out within yourself and they also
don't take offense to it because you
learned it somewhere but now you can
unlearn it and after you do that you
have the opportunity to change as well
well and I think you're right and I
think it's more important to talk about
firstly our own bias our personal bias
because calling out someone else's bias
is easy to do but it also creates
confrontation but I think if people
witness one another acknowledging their
own bias I think that will open up the
ability for people to have more sort of
truthful honest dialogue about it and
it's sort of coming from the me rather
than coming from the you yeah well I
think this was a very interesting
experience and I want to come away from
this dialogue with
a more open mind and open heart to
strangers and not automatically pass
judgment on them and just learn from
them and see what they're all about my
biggest takeaway is maybe how do we
structure that and I actually think the
video was helpful in terms of opening up
a dialogue it just really opened up the
door for all these avenues for our own
experiences to come through and it was
really cool yeah we're not that far
apart maybe I'll bump into you haha
yeah maybe I'll see you at the grocery
store or something all right well that
quickly became one of my my favorite
conversations of the day JC and garnet
spoke to all variety of things actually
half of which that I can absolutely
relate to and trigger experiences of my
own in terms of ambiguity in terms of
race and labeling and people's need to
to know what you are and I also learned
I learned a great deal and appreciated
JC kind of checking checking in what's
garnet about a couple things and talking
about a lie ship versus appropriation
and how to be responsible and thoughtful
in that process yeah I mean first of all
they were so cute it was such a pleasant
conversation I was like oh these like I
hope they become you know actually most
of their local so yes actually exactly
yeah and I think that I think they were
both incredibly respectful and they had
a lot of I think similarities and some
of their experiences of both living or I
guess sort of being ambiguous in how
they present gender wise and also you
know racially so I think I think that
this was a really productive
conversation right yeah very much
highlights in-group out-group and the
role that that plays I mean folks are
there making comments because that's how
they feel and we often
our surroundings boys will be boys
locker room conversation is probably
different in the locker room with a
bunch of sis jocks than it would be at
Thanksgiving dinner with a whole panoply
of other folks so we we constantly check
we have our inside outside conversations
in-group out-group conversations there's
a default to what are you and this is
coming from somebody who my entire life
probably the most common question that
has been asked of me the most popular
three words to me is what are you since
I was very little and it's in the first
five sentences of many interactions
since I was little what are you and what
is that question why do you why don't we
talk and you'll find out what I am
because people really see their actions
but you need to you need some kind of
label in order to categorize it's not
always ill intention but I've definitely
annoyed and for both of these folks they
it was nice to see them have a shared
experience because they probably don't
get it who am I to say but it's possible
they don't get it very often Garnett
certainly seemed like he doesn't have Oh
doesn't often get to relate to people on
that level of what it's like to be
ambiguous and always need to be labeled
there is also I think is worth
mentioning a difference between
ambiguity and looking like you're a
person of color versus being black nante
blackness is so specific and it's filled
with such vitriol and tradition in this
country at least that it kind of stands
on its own and I kind of I mean
definitely I was looking at some of
Professor Lori's notes and she was
saying that you know based on some very
specific research it has proven that
when strangers are walking about in the
world and you know we are passing each
other on the streets and sanny in line
behind each other at restaurants or etc
like those who are ethnically ambiguous
gets stared at way longer than those who
you're able to easily categorize and put
in a box and I wanted to know like have
you ever like found yourself you know
when you're walking through the world
aside from after because of the fact
you're Jesse Williams and you are well
known but even before then like have you
ever experienced like really noticing
like people glaring at you are knowing
that like someone is really like trying
to figure
well absolutely in my entire childhood
coming up especially because I lived in
entirely black areas entirely white
areas entirely poverty-stricken areas
entirely kind of little middle-class and
big you know and we have a lot of very
insulated pockets in this country and
I've lived in many of them and have not
fit in any of them so so yeah I've been
the object of that kind of staring and
and because they don't know the region
often comes with that you know I resent
the fact that you're making it harder
for me it's worth noting also just said
that JC rightly pointed out to Garnett
we should be thinking about how to be an
ally how to be a productive ally without
procreating culture making sure you are
still you authentic self without kind of
dipping and dabbing and sampling
cultures without actually having any
interest in the roots of their history
and how they're impacted in a multitude
of ways
alright let's go into another one of our
conversations this one is between Marlee
and she's talking to Renee
hello hi hi hi hi how are you I'm great
how are you good I'm Marley nice to meet
you I'm Rene nice to meet you as well
[Music]
so I I've seen that happen I mean I even
in LA is liberal progressive of a place
that we think we live in well it's
nothing new to me nothing new to us you
know something that we've come to expect
something that we experience a lot and
basically pretty much all the time
and it's a shame it's because it's it's
based on what we look like you can have
all the degrees in the world but it has
nothing to do with any of that you know
I went to high school there was like one
black family in my hometown and there
was a lot of that happening it happens
every day you see it every day I found
myself breathing hard my heart started
beating fast because it's so typical and
it makes me angry when you know we go
into a store it doesn't matter how
well-dressed we are you know sometimes
we're followed immediately you know
we're assumed you know and it bothers me
it really does and it's so unfair yeah I
just want to say to that Renee that I'm
bothered for you and it makes me so
angry there's so much that I'm learning
and I'm learning that I realize just
being born white and you know with a
certain privilege and where I grew up
that there's so much that's just innate
or learned behavior that you're learning
and I'm learning and I'm you know trying
so hard to just grow and break the cycle
and it's like if I just like hope that
we can keep moving forward Marlee you
know I appreciate and I think this is
what touches my heart so much is that at
least there's a willingness and that's
what I hear so much from you there's a
willingness to listen finally a
willingness to listen went for so many
years it seemed as though if we
mentioned something like that you know
the looks this is what are you talking
about what we Thomas somebody looked at
you for some reason we weren't believed
the curtain has been pulled back
showing the truth of our lives the truth
of what we've had to experience for so
many years it's so true and I was
protesting a couple days ago downtown
and this black man stalked me and he
because we were holding a black lives
matter sign and and he's like that
starts with you guys who are here
willing to fight put your bodies in
front of us you know and just like stand
up because I had a similar experience
and and this is the only way I can
relate where I can I'm never gonna
understand and I know that because of my
skin color I am very androgynous in the
way that I dress and express myself and
I've gotten threatening looks and those
those vibes like I know what you're
saying where it's hard to explain to
people like what are you talking about
like where I felt threatened because
people were afraid of the unknown you
know like they're afraid of what they
don't know so then trying to figure me
out is she a boy is she a girl and I've
had those I was I was followed into a
bathroom last fall because they thought
I was entering the wrong bathroom for my
sign gender and that was the first time
I felt fear like I was shaking and I'm
shaking just talking about it because
you know I was I was like who's this
person to come in here and tell me that
I'm not using the right bathroom you
know just based off of how I look but I
have that default of like I'm white and
as scared as I was I didn't think they
were gonna shoot me you know like I'm
never gonna know to that extent it's
like it frustrating you see on Facebook
and I have a mixed bag of like
progressives and conservatives because
I'm wearing from and there's still so
many people that it hasn't clicked in
and insane all lives matter and it just
shows me that we have a long way to go
but you're right there is like it's a
start
why do you think that they don't get it
why do you think is it because they
don't want to or do they think that
we're less fan I wish I could understand
that
I think it's everyone is trapped in
their bubble and doesn't have enough
exposure they don't have friends who are
of color yeah you can be nice to someone
a person of color but that doesn't mean
you have you know racist thoughts or
like in that video like you know you're
not gonna roll up your window or they
don't see like who you are at work
versus who you are I know I'm a
different person at work than I am you
know here at home with my girlfriend my
dog
you know I feel sorry for them if they
knew me you know they would recognize
that I am a human beings just like they
are you know they would recommend little
Michelle and God just like they are
why are we so hated in this country it
makes me angry and it hurts and I have
Grand Funk I worry about they're sweet
as they could be and they have to worry
about not coming home one day hardest
thing for any mother
and then to hear George Floyd the call
prison mama I don't I don't have kids
you know I would like to someday I was
just wondering if you could expand a
little bit on that you know how that
resonated with you when when George
Floyd did call out first mom well I
think as a mom you know I think that is
the greatest joy I think that you know
that I ever had was to have children and
it's just a miracle to me it doesn't
matter what color you are the fact that
you have this child you know that it was
that you cared into your heart so I mean
you would do anything to protect that
child to take it maliciously like that
in front of people and your child is
begging for their life thinking I can't
breathe it's just unbearable there are
no words
marlee there's just no words it's just
so much I think that we have to to help
people to understand how do you think
you can going forward help some people
understand I think I just need to be
more willing to have these uncomfortable
conversations especially with family
it's so much easier for me to not combat
what they're saying so to make it you
know easier for me but if I'm making it
easier for me I'm not making it easier
for you or people of color so I I know
that I need to start calling these
people out and you know it's a lot of
energy but it's it's worth the energy if
people are being murdered in cold blood
respect something about when you're at
work that you hide your true self
something like that what was that about
when I started working in the film
industry I work in art department
primarily there was a lot of men older
men when I when I joined and I'm a
drogyn Asst and you know I look like how
most Cali boys look with long blond hair
they would assume sometimes on my first
day at a new job that I was just some
young guy there was some times where I
felt like I had to hush my voice or not
speak until spoken to so that they
didn't hear the tone of my voice or the
high pitch because I felt like they're
gonna respect me first for being a man
you know like if there's something I
don't know how to do because I'm new
they're not gonna judge me like oh
because she's a young girl what made you
decide that you wanted to be androgynous
looking back now and like I said since
I've moved out here there's been so much
more than I've discovered about myself
in gender and being queer and you know
playing on the gender spectrum I have
this vivid memory of when I was little I
remember my dad and my brother were
outside playing my dad was like mowing
the grass and my brother never played
with the ball and and they both had
their shirts off and I kept pulling my
shirt off and my dad's like no you can't
do that and I just like didn't
understand why that was like taboo
that's how I feel now like I've had so
many issues with like body dysphoria and
ways that I feel about feminine parts of
my body that I just like have now
discovered but looking back there's been
incidences that were always there and it
was definitely difficult I was like the
black sheep of my family like I
definitely got made fun of a lot because
people just did not understand that I've
recently learned that the black LGBTQIA
community is disproportionately
marginalized do you have any insight as
to why that is well you know what Marlee
you're gonna have to do me a favor okay
because they keep adding letters to that
so would you do me a favor and break
and the new the new letters please
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
intersex a gender so I came out as a
lesbian when I was like 20 you know I
started to discover these parts of me
and realize it was always there but it
was just kind of suppressed because of
the area that I grew up in or you know
even my family like it was it was hard
for them because even though like I say
they're pretty progressive and
open-minded it always comes down to well
when it's your own kid it's like a
different story you know so I was just
kind of circling back just because I've
been seeing so many parallels in my own
personal growth and you know struggles
or obstacles that I've had to face that
like I said it's not comparable in the
sense that I will ever fully understand
but it's I think it's helpful in this
learning and unlearning process of
trying to draw your own experiences as
close as you can you know back in the
60s we didn't really talk about that
until I got older we didn't talk about
those things do you agree that
homosexuality is a sin or not you know
the way I was raised
in the word from adulthood is that the
that homosexuality in and of itself the
lifestyle of homosexuality is a thing
and in the Bible it does say that a man
shall not live with a man so according
to the Bible the Bible says everyone has
to live out their own salvation you are
going to live your life according to the
way you decide to live your life I'm not
gonna judge you that's not my place do
you think that being gay is a choice I
can't be sure I really can't be sure
because I don't understand you know just
just like you say that you don't
understand what it's like to be black
and what you've experienced which and
you know to be honest with you they're
not the same thing they're not being
homosexual and being black I can't even
equate the thing the two things because
they're not the same thing but my mind
not understanding almost sexuality I
don't I don't know if it's
physical thing a spiritual thing is
psychological thing I have no idea i I
can tell you that for me personally like
it's not it's not a choice there's been
times where like you know with people
not understanding sexuality or my gender
where there's been so many times it's
like if I just didn't feel like this of
course I would choose what the the
easier route you know like I would I
would choose being straight cuz that's
how society is more accepting you know I
guess if you know if we were to ever
able to meet in person and you saw
someone give me the discriminatory look
discriminatory look or made a comment to
me about my identity would you stand up
for me absolutely I would stand up for
you Marlee absolutely no one has a right
to discriminate against anyone yeah
anyone no one has that right yeah and
not just me but I guess or someone like
me or especially people you know in the
black LGBTQ community that's right no
one has that right thank you
it's just crazy that we don't even we've
never even met and like don't people are
gonna think this is like a plug I'm like
we've never met but like already just in
these two hours I feel so connected to
you because you have been so open and
willing to hear things that I've
struggled with and I'm just beginning to
only learn of the things that you've
struggled with but you've been willing
to listen and learn
just like I'm willing to listen and
learn and it's just really refreshing it
is refreshing and I think that's the
bottom line I think we have to be open
and willing to listen and learn doesn't
mean that we're going to agree on
everything right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so that was a really unique conversation
they were both really respectful I think
it was productive I think from jump
initially when Rene was explaining sort
of her reaction to watching the look and
saying you know she said she found
herself breathing hard at her hug and
her heart started beating quickly once
they entered the courtroom it's like
it's so interesting because I completely
relate to those feelings when I'm in
those types of uncomfortable situations
it's like this visceral like these body
reactions that I get that are you know
subconscious and you know I don't
realize that like oh my gosh I'm
actually soaked because I was sweating
out of nervousness for being you know
walking past his cop or you know
something like that and even you know
Marley brought up that she also
experienced that when she was walking
into the restroom and realized she had
been followed into the restroom and then
you know her body just had this reaction
because it's just like this this this
very specific reaction that I would be
so curious to know like white people who
check off all of these you know boxes of
power like do they ever really
experience these like body reactions
sometimes I think we get into a bit of a
sufferer off like a competitive
suffering like measuring who's had it
worse there is a difference between
saying I can relate to having that
feeling I've gotten that feeling when
this has happened in a coffee shop which
is different than saying I know exactly
what that's like what I did appreciate
was when Marley was explaining her
experience of having those body
reactions and sort of a little bit of
fear when she realized that she had been
followed into the restroom was that you
know she said that she was really scared
but she acknowledged that she wasn't
scared for her life which is a key
difference and I think the two
experiences and I think that it was
really beneficial and productive for her
to
validate her feelings and acknowledge
that this is how she felt in those
moments but that it is also not the same
yeah it's exactly how it should be done
right you can have a relation - you can
let somebody know they're seen without
making it equal I thought it was
interesting
in Renee's answer if I have this right
Marlee asked about how she'd feel how
Renee how do you feel do you think that
it's a choice do you think that it's a
sin and if I have it correctly I feel
like Renee answered not from the outset
how she thinks but what she was taught
taught which that could that shows
itself in other conversations that were
going through today - is a bit of a
pivot from really receiving the the
question kind of flush but saying you
know what I was taught was this which is
fine it's important to know but it's not
the answer it's not really confronting
how I feel and and I wonder why that is
you know Renee is very similar to a lot
of the older black women in my family
you know what I mean like who are you
know still trying to figure things out
and I haven't me having to explain what
non-binary is and all these things - the
older black folks in my family so it's
one of those things that you know can be
frustrating if you're not willing and
open to learn totally
especially in fairness that is an
ever-changing world of nomenclature I
don't want to put people off from being
curious with this kind of cancel culture
that was offensive because I want folks
who are absorbing this to feel like they
can ask questions find a way to do it
respectfully maybe don't go they keep
just saying hey I might not feel like I
might be updated yeah I think in general
my takeaway from Renee and Marley's
conversation was that it was more of
sort of like that generational push and
pull based on you know keeping up with
what's happening in the LGBTQ community
and also what's happening in the black
community Renee as a mother you know
really touching on as a mother and being
concerned that your child will return
safely home you know and won't be killed
or beaten at the hands of those and you
know privileged and empower okay the
police so I think there
a lot of different topics that were
touched on with this conversation and I
you know I kind of wish it could have
gone longer because I think that there
was a lot more to unpack especially on
Renee's end and learning more about
Marley and the queer community and
things of that nature so yeah I would
add I think that Renee even after the
call I would hope that she sits with the
challenges that were put before her the
difference between what I was taught and
what I actually think and maybe you
don't know what you think in that time
because now you're actually faced with
somebody
all right Jesse so our next pairing will
be Judy who's based in Texas and Martin
who's based in Illinois this this one
you see what you're doing and watch this
video please watch this one you guys I
think it's important not only because of
what happens but because of we know
folks with a lot of these perceptions
and we know the impact they can have so
but I further ado we give you Martin and
Judy
you
hello hi how you doing
Judy it is Thank You T what is shy name
I'm Martin a little bit of background
about me I'm married I've been married
since 2002 I have a four boys and they
range in age from thirty four all the
way down to eight how old are you now
you're getting personal thirty
four-year-old oh no no I'm 54 years old
I'm a grandfather yes the whole nine ah
what's your story Judy I'm 53 and I have
two daughters well this is a pleasure
meeting you
it's a pleasure meeting you
[Music]
hmm I didn't like what I just saw there
okay
[Music]
that wasn't very nice either them closed
an elevator door on my man that's that's
life in America because the first thing
you see when you see me is a black man
you have no idea what my educational
background is what my financial
background is what my upbringing is so
all you know is that I'm black the first
thing you see when I walk in the door I
can honestly say the only time I was
ever afraid being in a car and pulling
up my window was I don't know what you
call it in Chicago I think Cabrini Green
but it was out of safety other than that
I've probably been afraid of black
people and I've always given everyone
the benefit of the doubt but I don't
look at things like that I have a lot of
black friends you just kind of I don't
know you saw it in the film if this
guy's a judge he's probably brilliant
probably has money more money than both
of us but yet they looked at him almost
like he was a second-class citizen and
that's what I mean life in America like
I just what hurts me is seeing a lot of
black people hurting their own people do
you see any of that well I do see that
but always remember this Judy people
hurt the people that they live around so
I also know from statistics that white
people hurt and kill and fight other
white people in their areas because
that's who they're around so when I hear
about black on black crime I get it
because I see it I'm right - outside of
Chicago but I also know if you go into
certain areas where there's
predominantly white people they hurt
each other - if you were a situation
where someone pulled a gun on you no
matter what color and you pull your gun
out is that trying to protect yourself
or is that be you trying to kill
somebody
no that's self-defense see the problem
what with the reason why we're probably
on this line right now is because you've
seen and I'm sure you've seen on the
news if you talk to your black friends
and they really talk to you then you'll
know that where there's black people
armed that are being killed by police
sometimes is unprovoked sometimes it's
just because the police officer
quote-unquote fear for his life but it
was really nothing to fear you know
because the person was unarmed like if
you look at what happened to George
Floyd or look at Eric Gardner or look at
Jonathan cross this I can go on a
laundry list of black people that were
killed that were unarmed and I always
say well they make to him that could
have been me the problem we have is like
people we can't have a bad day with the
police you know I can't do like you
could do you can say hey get the hell
out of my face you Pig
why'd you pull me over you could do that
you could do that and get away with it
I've seen it I can't do that the minute
I even say Judi if I say but why'd you
pull me over you question it me get out
the car I've seen it it's like like
they're waiting for me to say the wrong
thing so that they could do the wrong
thing and this thing escalates that's
why I always use that term de-escalation
Judi because it never it doesn't have to
get that way what I'm learning is right
wrong or indifferent
no one is respecting the police force
there's some bad ones in there but
they're not all bad so what's kind of
scary for me is going forward who wants
to join the police force they're damn
good they're due and they're damned if
they don't you know George Floyd had a
laundry list of bad crimes trust me and
believe in me that guy should not have
done what he done what I don't like or
what I don't agree with if you don't
mind me saying and help me understand
this is to use him as a murder we never
said that George Floyd was our hero we
just know that he died needlessly and he
this this death was the catalyst that
sparked this movement not he wasn't
combative he was subdued
he was already in cuffs and surrounded
by police and he was on drugs well see
he could have been on a lot of drugs but
when you saw him that at that point
where that officers knee was on his neck
there was no struggling there was no
wailing and for him fighting he was
already in cuffs correct you'd
absolutely okay
so whether
and this is why I don't I'm not getting
on you because I hear this all the time
whenever one of us dies at the hand of
the police or vigilante we'll come up
with something that Trayvon Martin
smoked reefer or Eric Gardner shouldn't
have been selling loose cigarettes
you'll hear every type of way to justify
those deaths and that's why I'm going it
wouldn't see my thing to you is even if
he was on drugs I think some people are
under the impression that we're
idolizing some of these people as heroes
when we're not we're we're really more
focused on the incident and the
injustice of the incident than the
person their background how it happened
versus kind of why it could have
happened or what their background was
because to us it's two different avenues
my question to you is what if police
officers do and not in this case because
obviously this guy and he's charged with
murder and it's the way it should be
they are up against a lot of bad people
and now they're afraid to defend
themselves because as soon as they do
they're ridiculed for it all we want
them to do is give us the same
opportunity to surrender and comply that
they do with white people let me give
you a couple of instances if you
remember a guy named Dylan roof shot up
nine black people in a church they took
him to Burger King a lie the guy had the
Aurora killer who killed the people in
the theater
they took him alive I got a young man by
the name of tear mere Rice twelve years
old and Ohio they pull up on him within
less than two seconds Judy that 12 year
old young man was dead so my question is
well how did you not give him a chance
to comply get on the ground
throw your weapon down you could have
did that from the PA so all we want is
the same respect in the same type of
compassion and a chance to surrender
give me a chance to at least go sir I'm
not doing anything here let me live and
I can plead my case I understand what
you're saying I think that they exam
that you're you said and you're giving
me a peel the there are more examples of
black-on-black crime than what you're
giving me right now and it's true
black-on-black crime is over-the-top I
can give you all type of examples if you
want me to I feel if they can stop doing
that to each other
I truly believe things would be better I
wanted to interject because I've said
this to people and I want to get your
take on it black people know that gang
bangers drug dealers and thieves killing
raw people we don't get when police do
it you see that's the difference like if
you want to talk about black-on-black
crime
I got you it's a problem is the issue
but I don't expect a police officer to
be that gun wielding and shooting me
down like the gangbanger did like where
I can't win gonna be honest with you I
didn't see the whole thing um if it's
disturbing enough wait the first police
officer dead I'll say this the ads are
police officer suicide we happen he's
under cuff let's go that's wrong in my
mind what they did was wrong like they
should have stopped him and put him in
the court system cheaper to defend
himself I believe that but I also
believe that not every white cop out
there it's a bad person and only wants
to kill black people like I don't
believe that I think they try to do
their job and it's gotten a lot
difficult to do that because of these
situations so I understand that but I
also know that they need to step up like
you just said if they see a wrongdoing
they need to step up what you're seeing
on the news is the filming of it there's
a bunch of white people getting beat up
killed choked out and abuse that you
will never see because it wasn't taped
but this has been going on for decades
we've been being beaten and locked up
for no reason in the whole night
but now we're seeing it more aunty
there's always an epidemic or protests
or something right before an election I
think that has something to do with it
like people are getting killed all the
time it doesn't happen just in an
election year when Sandra bland or
Trayvon Martin E or or Eric Gardner or
Freddie great like these things are
happening every several hunts right you
see it on the news so it has nothing to
do with an election cycle this just
happened to happen at you know during
this time but what's to stop something
from happening in October right before
the November election oh it's going to
have those things happen so often we can
almost predict it'll be another video
that comes out at some point there's
somebody getting dragged around or beat
around Y now like why are you because
there was there is no excuse now but it
made even white people say he was not
resisting arrest
he was already in handcuffs there were
multiple cops around this was the one
that you couldn't deny like you could go
well Trayvon this Eric Gardner wasn't in
cuffs yet Rodney King wasn't in cuffs
yet this thing we're still a threat but
that's all I hear I all I hear from my
counterparts white people they always
can find a way to say well you know he
was a bad guy he was bad with this one
even though George Floyd might have had
a background in history when he was
being killed as you even pointed out he
was subdued on his stomach in cuffs
around he wasn't going anywhere
so for him to die that way even the
majority of everybody who saw that tape
I don't know too many people that
wouldn't agree would be because at the
end of the day if you're unarmed and you
weren't really a threat you should be
alive so if they look me up and I'm
driving and they pull me over they're
gonna find out I have a concealed carry
permit okay what do you how do you think
they should interact would be at that
point do you have a concealed weapon on
you yes or no you say yes sir I do
it's right here okay you're being honest
they're being honest hey Judy you
remember falando Castillo volando
castile was in another Michigan resident
had a concealed carry permit tells that
he's not even driving his girlfriend's
driving tells the cop I have a concealed
carry permit when I reach inside this
glove compartment
you know you're gonna see the weapon but
this is where my insurance and
registration is he opens up the glove
compartment puts one right into his
heart he would open see but that that's
our thing like even when we're honest
and open and and and totally transparent
we catch it okay let me ask you a
question who should police the police
the citizens the same people that are
putting mayor's in their seats chief of
police in their seat all you have to do
is get what we call the citizens panel
it doesn't have to be a ton of people it
could be six or seven people from
different backgrounds and let them look
at the different scenarios and say okay
I think we got a bad a canary our
background education like you just like
some ordinary citizen to start policing
the police don't those seems normal in
every citizens act those jurors in the
court okay that actually scares me
because what scares us is a prosecutor
who works with the police every single
data to prosecute crimes now calling
himself being unbiased and neutral
policing that police officer that killed
my son because of course you're not
really neutral you're not non biased you
work with that guy every day you guys do
coffee go bowling how do I know you're
gonna give me justice for my kid we got
to do better we can do better we just
got to figure out the system to put in
place to make and hold people
accountable and force them to do better
because we can't keep doing this we can
okay what I've got out of this whole
conversation is two people both believe
things are wrong all right things need
to be fixed and I believe we had a
really good conversation coming up with
a good solution to learning from Martin
yeah and I feel that this conversation
was beneficial also because there I get
a chance to kind of see where people are
coming from outside of my community and
I wouldn't thank Judy for her time
taking part in this conversation being
open and honest with us because it was
great
Thank You Martin I agree it's really
good
nice to meet you and it was a pleasure
thank you you tell I don't know where to
start with this one Freddy I think that
there is um a whole lot to unpack here
and I am you know Frank grateful for the
opportunity I think we checked a lot
this conversation checks a lot of the
boxes that are in popular belief and on
websites and comment threads so I'm
firstly I would like to point out we've
all we all know it the go-to distracting
move when talking about putting its boot
on the neck of citizens with those
citizens happened to be black is that
ever distracting
what about black on black crime I would
say that whenever you're on a topic in a
conversation and the other person needs
to change the subject
they are conceding the point yes as
Martin rightly points out crime is
proximate okay people eat drink worship
often work in proximity to where they
dwell so that's that 85 percent of white
people are killed by at the hands of
other white folks there's very little
difference in terms of those stats again
George Floyd's murder as they were
talking about there was no black on
black crime involved your address is
effective talking about how ham
sandwiches are made
she also I wonder what he think about
the default I have black friends move
what does what does that mean if I if
I'm what does that mean I know when do
we employ that we don't employ that
we're talking about sexual assault oh
well I know I my sister's a woman that
has nothing to do with what we're
talking about there's some early early
elements of the conversation that stood
out to you before we even jump it is I
just want to say how important it is to
really see some of these conversations
play out in real time because you
mentioned echo chambers earlier and how
we all are sort of you know really
inundated with our own echo chambers and
it's all down so like who we follow on
Instagram who we follow on Twitter that
our news sources like everything is
pretty much
like in line with I think our worldviews
and so you know when you see things
floating around like well what about
black-on-black crime and well you know
he had he was on drugs so that's that's
why it was okay you know things like
that those are all just kind of like
whispers in the air for me cuz I don't
surround myself with people who speak
that way or who talk about these topics
in that way so to see it play out in
real time
like this with Judy and Martin was
honestly really enlightening to me it
was very triggering you know throughout
multiple parts of the conversation but I
was like wow like these really you know
people really have these beliefs and are
passionate about them it's not only like
well I don't really know the answer but
like this is what I think it's like no
Judy was very very confident in her
outlook and honor view with these
scenarios and so it was just you know
was really interesting to also watch
Martin so gracefully you know give his
point of view if I took anything from
this conversation was just padagu it was
how to be graceful and patient this is a
perfect example of the role that bias
can play and the connective thread
between a simple bias and the loss of
life and violence upon someone else if I
am predisposed if I have been taught and
doctrine ated is a better word to
believe that black people are more prone
to violence like men are more prone to
violence they're more likely to be
criminals which is to say less worthy of
the rights which they are promised and
pay taxes for and it's woven into the
fabric of this nation if they're more
likely to be violent then when I see an
example or really not see anything when
I hear somebody on a comment in Fred say
they had a criminal history I'm more
likely to make that pathology pathology
to be violent offenders when in the
history of the world clearly there is no
one close to as violent as the white
male or white society it's not even
close when you hear a new word you start
hearing that word everywhere so your
antennas only up for specific dog
whistles specific catch phrases specific
terms and visuals so she has this little
little little mini box of five cliches
and three sentences that just rotate
well black on black crime well that
doesn't apply here
okay but he had drugs in his system and
he did crime before okay give me a list
of crimes that are punishable by
spontaneous public execution there are
none we have a system of law and order
you said we should follow it we should
let the system take its course why
aren't we doing that when their skin is
dark when white violence doesn't count
but black violence can be amplified at
any moment when black life never matters
because its value can be snatched away
in a second with a tweet but white value
is perpetual because despite its best
effort it always says value are they
shooting up a school or a church you
give them the benefit of the doubt
that's it's a really tough mountain to
climb and Martin did an excellent job
trying but I'm glad that we have this
conversation on display where you really
have to be open at the beginning of a
conversation to learn something yeah
absolutely and I think to Professor
lip-read had sort of flag at the term
aversive racism which i think is really
evident in this conversation with Judy
and Martin which is a versus of racism
is the lack of contact with the group
creates stereotypes right and so I think
it's pretty clear that like you know
judy has she says that she has black
friends right that does not mean that
she has made a habit of surrounding
herself with people who are unlike her
own in order to learn and sort of break
down some of those stereotypes
throughout life so you know she was
saying that after the look after they
watched the look she was saying you know
I've never rolled up my windows or
locked my door except for when I was in
computing yeah for safety right and I
think to white people really like to
instead of saying black neighborhoods
they'll say high crime areas which is
just code for black neighborhoods
because of redlining and because of the
history of this country and really
segregating these communities in ways
that black people specifically cannot
control so I think that was something
that really stood out to me there was
just so many points you know I think
that we could talk about this
conversation
you know for hours because there's just
so much to unpack here but I think
Martin did a really good job of drawing
parallels to white criminals and how
they're treated versus how black
suspects are treated and I think you
know one of the quotes that stood out
and even most was you know give us a
chance to surrender like they did Dylan
roof I want to just try to put it
concisely what judy is a real example of
is how your bias can come to any case
and remix and repurpose the entire
experience if my bias for an unarmed
handcuffed man on the ground is well he
was violent yeah but not this time well
he had a history yeah but that wasn't
part of this yeah but he could have if
if you're you're lobbing you we you we
weaponize our bias it gives a pre
checklist instead of actually being
present and letting that person be a
human being
it really is worthy of examination and
we have these and we have folks just
like her in our family a lot of us do
and and that is where there's a real
opportunity to to break some new ground
here because what it what are you
without as Toni Morrison said what are
you without your racism are you any good
is there a reason you're hiding from it
what are you without it what if we can
actually just talk about these
individuals that's that's the challenge
so for our next pairing we're going to
be joining Eric who's based in Florida
and Danielle who's based in Illinois and
you guys I was really nervous going into
this one so tune in
hi Eric hi hi Danielle I just saw your
name pop up there how are you I'm great
how are you
I am well so what do you do for work I
am in education so I teach at a law
school and I'm a lawyer by trade oh so I
gotta watch what I say yeah that's
awesome I I've been a cop for 20 years
and so my least favorite place is the
courthouse don't feel intimidated by him
by the face
[Music]
oh please let him be the judge
[Music]
Shh
Oh
[Music]
now I love it that gave me chills I like
that I was taken by this black man kind
of going about his everyday life and
experiencing what I would call
microaggressions just from the look and
people automatically having certain
opinions or thoughts about that about
that individual and you know changing
their demeanor because of just seeing
him as a black man or a black person you
see that happen you know people who
drive through neighborhoods and locked
the doors if you lock them because it's
a high crime area okay if you lock them
because you see somebody just walking a
totally different you know one thing
that troubles me Erik sometimes is
seeing the different ways in which
officers handle black offender I guess
I'll call it an offender a black
offender versus a white offender and how
white offenders can you know honestly
cut the complete fool and still be
arrested where you know black folks just
don't have that kind of experience and
they end up harmed often and sometimes
dead it's not acceptable what what the
officers historically have done but I
also looking at the sheer number of
encounters you know that hey not all of
them are bad Eric what is it like to be
a police officer right now it's horrible
because we get judged and this is gonna
sound very familiar by what others have
done I understand as a police officer
this is kind of you know this is
unfortunate you know one one of the
things I would say about the Floyd the
George Floyd situation is there were
officers that were surrounding him right
and none of those officers did anything
and I'm not saying that every one police
is like that but what I am saying is it
seems like when officers see something
wrong there is this kind of code of
silence
I'm not you know I'm not going to do
anything about it and I think that also
impacts the perception of police
officers if more officers said we will
not stand for this this is not
acceptable we do not want to perpetuate
discrimination we don't want to
perpetuate racism that is not who we are
and what we are about as opposed to kind
of holding on to that themselves but not
stepping up and you know and and and
breaking that code of silence oh I agree
I think some of the things that stopped
officers from saying something is that
if the person they observe doing it is a
senior officer they think well I I'm a
junior officer what do I know or if
they're a higher rank well one day I
want to be to their rank so I want them
on my good side when these type of
horrific events go on in other parts of
the country we talk about it because the
best thing we can do is to not have it
happen to us but is to talk about well
why did this happen
how can we keep from this happening here
so regarding the incidents around George
Floyd I haven't seen enough to say of
the entire video to say that officer did
that to that man because he was black
what I'd seen was an officer who had a
subdued subject who was not flailing
around on the ground keep his knee and
obstruct his airway from what I observed
and there was no need for that I think
it's I hear you and understand kind of
the perspective of the department but I
would just I really challenge that
because I think that you know we're
talking about bias and people have
biases and police officers have biases I
just I find it hard to believe that had
he been a white man or even a white and
certainly not a
a white woman the officer directly
involved with the knee on his neck as
well as the officers that were
surrounding that were standing there
looking on would have handled it that
way can you imagine oh that officer
having his knee on a white woman's neck
like that for ten minutes that would not
that would not have happened right I'm
gonna tell you I agree that do you think
do I think that I would see it as a
white lady and officer Nate no I agree
with you but you look at the Orlando
Police Sergeant she was a black female
she got murdered by a black suspect but
there was no black lives matter movement
for that and that's what frustrates me
is you don't see the outcry of police
officers getting shot and killed and
sometimes I scratched my head and I
wonder I'm like why why is that people
have kind of misunderstood that black
lives matter was an affirmation directly
related to black people being killed by
the police if you are an officer and
that is your line of work there's a
potential that someone you know may harm
you may kill you whether they're black
white or what-have-you but the
expectation in terms on the flip side if
you are a citizen is that you will not
be killed by the police you know like
you said we sign up we put on a badge a
gun and we go to the work expectation to
come home but the reality is you may not
and a large part of me feels extremely
said that the black lives matter
movement has got intertwined with
rioters because that's not it there's a
big difference between protesting and
rioting you know black folks are a press
community and we've been oppressed for
he for the 400 years that we've been
here and you know slavery with all kinds
of policies that negatively affected our
lives and our abilities to live the
American dreams people have to
understand the history to really
understand why those feelings are so
deep-seeded when I think about you know
what happened in Tulsa and what happened
in Rosewood where you know black people
who were sustaining their communities
and were thriving economically were
bombed and slaughtered by white people
we have to keep in mind all of these
experiences so when you're looking at
young people out who are protesting
peacefully who are rioting who are
looting I think that it's all a
combination of just that frustration
however it went down it's gotten the
attention that it's that it's needed to
get so I know that and I'm anti looting
but I'm Pro protesting okay so why loot
and I said okay so because I've heard
people say well they're stealing the
looters are stealing from the
communities which they live in and then
I saw something else that said property
beat can be replaced lives can't so then
they got me thinking so if I'm a looter
other than just personal greed I'm
stealing from a store the store
typically has insurance so the store
will be made whole but I'm getting my
media attention like you said I'm
getting you know I'm getting notice
whether it's good or bad I'm getting
noticed so as much as I don't agree with
it the insurance companies pay out well
if you're paying out more money than
you're bringing in that's a problem for
business and that's a problem for these
CEOs the CEOs and who runs them
typically powerful white men how do they
get in business who do they know
typically politicians so do I try to
look at it as that that a looter is
saying this is the only way I can get
the powerful person's attention white
black Hispanic typically white if you
look at the makeup of Congress this is
how I get their attention do I agree
with it absolutely not have I tried to
understand it yes
so that's great that you have tried to
understand and just broaden your
perspective on it the recourse that
people have to change unjust systems is
protesting advocating doing policy work
and trying to get to the root causes of
some of these these issues so people are
in the streets they're angry they're
rioting because they're trying to get
awareness and attention to this issue
because for so long they've gone through
these different kind of measures of
change and recourse without action
really being taken or without action
taking to the extent that it needs to be
done to tell people how they should
protest and what what they should do and
what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate I think is is out of line
this country was founded by people who
protested you know the Boston Tea Party
and all of these beings where they
looted and tore things up and so on you
know the feeling of desperation the
feeling of not having is what pours into
the looting part of it or the rioting
part of it one of the things I'd love to
see is not just hey we're here and we
want change but what is acceptable the
now the new thing is the disbanding and
defunding of police departments that is
the pushing I mmm what there's a real
reform look like what does the funding a
police department look like the core
that is about money
since we're paying them we want
accountability if money from policing is
diverted to education you know wouldn't
that be helpful for the police I like
that because it makes me go okay so it's
maybe not a hundred percent a bad thing
what can I do to say this is a step in
the right direction one thing is just
kind of being educated on these issues
you know there's all kinds of ways to
address to learn about bias because we
all have them
that they're not more officers that are
stepping up to say no this is not how
these situations should be addressed and
this is you know this is a result of you
know a bias or whatever it is but
officers taking on this issue oh I agree
that you have got to have a sense of
this is the job you want to do don't let
anybody call anything into question do
the right thing all the time thanks Eric
for this opportunity and joining in this
very important conversation that that
needs to be had we need that we are all
dependent on each other for you know
having some actionable things take place
we know that there is a process that
needs to get started but what I can't
tell you is I I
I certainly appreciate you you represent
the city of Chicago very well so they
should be very proud because I am a
better person for spending the last
couple hours with you thank you
same here
[Music]
so one of the first things that jumped
out at me in this conversation dress at
the outset I just want to have a
through-line a seventies of several of
these other conversations we have seen
this through line of one of the
participants reacting to the look the
video by mentioning whether they liked
it or not whether they agree with it or
not and man Eric really took me on a
journey there's some times where my
assumption based on what he does for a
living as a deputy sheriff or maybe just
the direction of his language sounded
like he was going to land somewhere but
he kind of took us on a ride and
actually had been quite thoughtful about
he kind of took us through behind the
curtain as to how we process things and
weighed pros and cons in an interesting
way that was a little more fleshed out
then I think folks often do so I
actually appreciated that a couple times
in the conversation around has he broke
down the rationale or or or end result
of so-called looting yeah yeah I think
to something that jumped out from jump
in this video was that as soon as
Danielle told him and revealed that
she's a lawyer you could sort of see
Eric's reaction to that and I think that
you know I think he was a little bit
intimidated by the fact that she's a
lawyer and she they would be engaging in
this conversation about bias and so I do
wonder like if she had a different
occupation or if you felt a little bit
more comfortable and less like you know
feel like you need to stay on his toes
would he wouldn't would he have spoken
to her or spoken about this topic in the
same way
Eric lean a distinction between pro-jobs
Pro protesting I'm against looting but
understanding that we can't we talk
about policing with the nether than the
major through-line is never the worst
among them as the headline protesting
has very little to do with white
annotation and so-called anarchist
people bussing themselves in to protest
to destroy obviously be destroying
property and instigating property damage
but it
Trax it's easily if you're not
interested in the subject matter it
detracts from the story it has to be
addressed in a dominant fashion it eats
up time and energy instead of talking
about the real the real frustration but
he did land on an interesting point
about about looting actually being the
only way to get some people's attention
yeah which was great it seemed like he
had really thought it through versus
just saying like you know you know these
folks are taking advantage of the
situation there it's stealing they're
doing X Y Z which is the way to deflect
from the actual issue at hand and I
think that that's it's important that we
keep calling that out these deflections
that keep coming up in these
conversations and we are in a time which
we are now of really having a public
conversation about transformational
change around policing we're talking
about defunding the police people trying
to figure out what exactly that does and
does not mean in order to really be
present for and active in that
conversation you do need to understand
some of the context that they're laying
out so that that's a step towards saying
okay if this is not working in the way
it claims to be working if it was we
wouldn't have to talk about it if people
felt both protected and served we'd be
on to a different topic we defund things
all the time what do you fund education
would defund health care we do on public
assistance we reduce funding in those
departments and it seems like I felt
like Eric really started in a good place
in that he was open and would be open to
kind of understanding that we actually
have a lot of these mechanisms in place
and as a police officer I think he
embodies what a lot of of deputy
sheriff's or police officers however you
define law enforcement in that case they
know they're not the ones to call for
they're exhausted they know they're not
the ones to call for mental health
crises or when you lost your dog or for
a domestic or a neighbor neighbors
arguing with each other about the sound
or a driver who pulled over to fall
asleep you know they know they're not
the one that they're spread thin on
these issues and if they're only trained
to enforce criminal code with various
forms of violence doing us all a favor
by taking that off their plate and
putting that into a safer a safer place
so I was glad to see
he was open to kind of wrestle with an
idea and not have a easy deflective quip
mm-hmm
and I wanted to really quickly just
touch on the idea of around morality as
a police officer or as a deputy sheriff
or just working in that field in general
one thing that stuck out to me was Eric
was saying that you know when all else
fails or you know if anything's ever in
question I teach my trainees to always
do the right thing and that is it's too
broad of an idea when people's lives are
in your hands right so it's like you
know we're sure that the police officer
who was on George Floyd's neck thought
he was doing the right thing sure your
bias directly affects what you think in
that moment is the right thing to do so
if we're not all addressing our biases
and because they have the power to you
know really crap and mold these things
the outcomes of these situations then
there's a larger conversation that needs
to be had within these police
departments because you know I mean it
all starts with bias and it really
inject like across the board can truly
affect whether someone lives or dies
alright let's dive into our next
conversation we have Fred calling in
from Pennsylvania and we have Paul from
Colorado
there we go sweet hey Fred how you doing
good how are you doing Paul oh just
peachy man huh were you from oh you're a
handsome lad thank you
I'm originally from Montreal married
with children
I married a Puerto Rican women two years
ago I heard of that I got a 22 and a 21
year old they're gorgeous kids
oh that's very black my oldest son is
the engineer and my daughters go to
private school
I'm oldest next oldest son was going to
private school as well for a while so
we're fortunate to be able to provide
our kids with yeah a you know that kind
of education let me intercept your what
you just said that we're very fortunate
that we can do this where does that mean
that means that I grew up in a pretty
rough neighborhood I had very serious
run-ins with the police as a child I've
been arrested four times by the police
I've been roughed up by the police
several times I had two unfortunate
experience of bearing over 50 kids from
gang violence and then I had a kid down
my arms in 91 and so I've known death a
lot
I say fortunate because I've been able
to ascend in job in the job market in
our region I become the first black CEO
of the company I'm currently in charge
of I can't relate to what you're talking
about because where I come from we don't
have these issues the big the biggest
problem I had growing up as a kid it
wasn't race for me I grew up French okay
I didn't learn to really speak English
until I was 12 most of my education was
all in French and my but my name was
English that caused problems at school I
got into a lot of fights in the
schoolyard alleys or whatever because I
had an English name and I lived in a
French sector a lot of bombs were going
off in English sectors and my mom is
very concerned about that because I was
going to school in an English area then
I ended up moving back to Colorado in
1996 and I've been here ever since
[Music]
I can't agree to a lot of the visuals I
just saw because that's just not who I
am
I've never been a part of that and never
will and so I find it disturbing and I
think the the idea the deep idea has
really not improved
for me unfortunately I've resonated very
much with the video in particular him
being a judge I have some love love
recognition in the city of Pittsburgh
and so I actually I get treated
differently if I come into a place and
I'm dressed down people don't even speak
to me people that have known me for
years and so people are used to this
soup being me I would say from a context
perspective there has always been
slavery all around the world for
millennia oh yeah the kind of slavery
that took place in America is the only
one of his kind chattel slavery for 246
years America used black people from the
continent from sunup to sundown to
create a superpower in less than 200
years after 246 years of slavery it was
followed by 135 years of institutional
racism Jim Crow laws realigning making
it illegal for blacks to have the same
benefits of their white counterparts
even after they went to fight in a world
wars and now in America we have 55 years
of alleged freedom and equity which many
of us in America don't see that way and
I can tell you that my experiences as a
black man with education haven't went to
school several times I am challenged
every day
by microaggressions I'm challenged when
I walk in the store I know that feeling
of sitting in the restaurant and people
being directed to sit near you and they
go no I want to sit over here I know
that and you have to tell your child
it's okay when it's not okay and so Paul
was very interested and struck by your
experiences and also struck by the fact
that that video didn't move you because
you never had that experience and that's
not you but were you able to for a
moment put yourself in that person's
shoes and window and just wonder for a
brief moment what that might feel like
well let me interject here first of all
it's not that it didn't move me it did
it pissed me off you know I'm just not
seeing that this country as I mentioned
earlier is really improving have you
ever thought about or had to give to
talk to your daughter or to your new
children in your marriage about any kind
of interaction where their race or
beliefs might cause them some social
discomfort or be challenged by
authorities if I had to have a
conversation with my kids about this it
would be hard for me because I wouldn't
know pretty much where to start because
I mean I haven't had this problem but
you know what you have to because is
they're being bombarded with this 24
hours a day how I treat and talk to my
children is very much reflective of the
environment that they walk into every
day one of the most difficult
conversations I've had to have with my
son's is how to conduct yourselves when
the police pulled them over and they
will get pulled over I'm
difficult conversation was years ago
ever my oldest son drive one of my
vehicles and being pulled over by the
police and harassed physically because
he was driving a very expensive vehicle
then the office would film up against
the vehicle and start harassing him
about how what does his father do her
mother do and so you know that really
hurt us what you see today in the
marching and the sit-ins and the
protesting it's really saying enough is
enough
you've had our your foot on our necks
literally for 400 years and we're not
going to take it anymore
well I'm gonna say something about the
the protest movements you know the the
change or the difference I've found is
that they became this this became global
you know you were having different
countries in the world that were walking
around with banners on what happened to
George even my country now I've got some
interesting feelings about this looting
and this all this stuff that's going on
behind the protesters because that's not
the message so I think that that's
something that might have been thrown in
the wash and tainted why don't you look
at the other side of the fence you know
the police department you know what
they're dealing with okay they got a job
to do and but you know I think some of
them unfortunately take that that badge
and the equipment that comes with it a
little too seriously
and unfortunately that's there's a
problem there and it's everywhere in
this country okay we know we got a side
line of cops that work together as a
unit they back each other up and they're
all part of a little clique that
sometimes causes problems like this and
they feel because they have this uniform
they can take all this Authority one of
the things I honor about people is when
people are transparent and fully
vulnerable and and
I think that's something that men in
particular struggle with our bravado our
disposition the things people expect us
to do and focus on it really has created
a false sense of control for us and so
you know Paul feel like we've we come
from two different sides of the world
there are some similarities and how we
were raised
I'll tell you something right now in
comparison to where we relate again is
that growing up I didn't have anybody to
to guide me I didn't have a father okay
I didn't have a father to guide me to
give me wisdom to teach me to basically
even back me up and so my whole life was
a kid I was I had like a mask on and I
was always trying to be something that I
I wasn't because I didn't feel like I
was good enough it's funny in order to
talk to more we have similarities up I
grew up from a broken home a mother and
father divorced when I was young yeah
when you allow yourself to listen to
another person's perspective you realize
that many of their experiences mirrors
your own but when you dig deeper and
this is with implicit biases I can look
at him and he can look at me and go
ahead that's a black guy I could go
that's the white guy but after an hour
and a half two hours were two different
people who happen to have one brown
brown skin one white skin but the people
who possess those skins are not defined
by black or white and I think that's the
importance of having conversations about
bias and implicit bias is that it allows
us to expand our own horizons and a way
to push us to new levels of
understanding appreciation and patience
that is required for us to figure out
how we're going to turn this thing
around I mean Paul it's the totality of
all of our experiences that are going to
offer solution
to the global phenomena we face I can
just see us you know bumping into each
other in a bar and we would have this
conversation and I'm pretty sure he
doesn't say you're not from your RT and
but there should be more people that are
not from here
once you find that kindred spirit it's
really about honoring their humanity in
ways that allows the DNA of the exchange
the conversation to live in a part of
you so that you always honor the person
who moved you or filled your vessel with
a different fluid that allows you to
have more diversity of thought action
and belief so I appreciate that and
thank you as I would say I love pushing
for what one of me which means until
next time my friend we have long as you
don't say it twice that means you gotta
go somewhere all right love you lovely
handshake
yes sir okay bye-bye back
[Music]
you
well that was a cute little ending to a
conversation I felt like they had this
like really beautiful camaraderie and
almost like a brotherhood by the end
which was really refreshing and nice to
see just a reminder you guys these are
strangers this was their first time and
we're speaking to in meeting one another
so the fact that they were able to share
experiences and sort of compare and
contrast and then you know ended on such
a really loving note was really nice
yeah it was like it was sweet I think
that it's also an example because
they're very different they have very
different experiences as we're
highlighted through the conversation
which we'll talk about and some
presuppositions and misunderstandings or
different understandings of reality but
what it does show is really for me the
value of these conversations because you
start where you are it doesn't matter if
you're 15 or 55 you start where you are
in terms of exposure and wrestling with
new ideas being challenged on your
position there is no too early in this
case we're talking about adults to have
these conversations I feel like Fred
challenged all on a lot of his
presuppositions we talked about the
aging up of black youth this this making
them you know we've had studies that
demonstrate that there is after about
nine ten years old black miners become
adults they get older than the way they
actually are to make them more
threatening they are inflated their
persona is inflated to make it more
dangerous menacing easy to be described
as a threat these are things that Paul
was familiar with but whenever he gets
exposed to it he will be forever changed
you can't unsee and unlearn historical
context so that's really one of the
beautiful things about about having
these conversations I want to quickly
jump into the idea of parenting and sort
of the difference between you know how
white people are raising their children
versus how black people are raising
their children and the conversations and
how the conversation is different right
so Paul was saying you know he wouldn't
even know where to start in terms of
having these conversations with his kids
about racism about bias about prejudice
and how to be more aware of your own so
that you can make the lives of others
who are different from you better like
help them have a little bit more of a
better day than they may have previously
experienced before coming
with them but then Fred was saying like
after watching the look he was like oh
yeah I can you know I can completely
relate to all of these scenarios I've
had the elevator doors shut on me
people have locked their doors when I've
walked by and you know he's and he has
you know he wears suits for work so he
notices a real difference in how he's
treated when he's wearing a suit and
then when he's out with his kids and
he's microaggression has happened he has
to sort of you know lay low not get to
you know visually upset and sort of to
calm the situation and to deescalate it
tell his kids you know it's okay it's
not a problem when it is a problem and I
think that that's something that I think
that you know I can absolutely relate to
in terms of just sort of that you know
how I was raised versus I think you know
how some of my white counterparts were
raised who don't really deal with that
yeah it's exhausting to have to
consistently pace yourself and be able
to make it do I use all my energy on
this now do I change the whole the whole
experience in the room or do I want to
just get out of here and take a breath
and do it in the car or later the degree
to which we don't have control over the
onslaught control over when the wave is
gonna crash on us and what a luxury it
is to just not ever have to be
confronted with this or after talk to
your family about it and just being able
to go about your life pursuing your
dreams and interests and whether the
realities of our experience is not for
you to agree doesn't matter of agree or
disagree it's a matter of do I care or
do I not and being interested I think a
big takeaway for me was also sort of had
to do with the short film the look and
you know black man walking through the
world being mistreated and then the
reveal at the end is that he's a judge
but I think something to really
highlight here is that even if he was
not the judge even if he was the bailiff
or even if he was the custodian he still
does not deserve to be treated in any of
those ways even if people who belong
that marginalized communities are not
stand-up citizens or aren't heroes they
still deserve respect and they still
deserve to go home at the end of the day
decency fairness and freedom does
not have to be relearned every time a
black person steps outside of their
house when why people just get to be
white
alright let's go and do this
conversation which really stood out to
me this is between Kayla who calls in
from New York and Angela calling in from
California there are some gyms
[Music]
hi hi I'm Angela I'm Kayla
nice to meet you you too
[Music]
I feel like I have experienced the look
my whole life in higher education in
predominantly white spaces like people
assuming I don't belong somewhere or
wondering why I am somewhere for me what
really stood out is having these stairs
and while I didn't grow up with fat
actually growing up it was quite the
opposite no one's seeing me as an Asian
American and then now we go from in the
time-of-flight Cove in nineteen we go
from invisibility to hyper disability so
when I walk out that door I am hyper
vigilant of the ways in which I take up
space right if I sneeze if someone gonna
give me a dirty look are people gonna
scoop back when they see me because I'm
Asian and me to have been hurt by
systemic injustice yeah everyone has
their own biases everyone is by it in
some way about something or somebody and
then the line between just being biased
and being racist is like what you do
after that I think it's important to
talk about bias because it dispels any
taboo or stigma there is right when you
name it when you call it out when you
know what it is it kind of washes the
light like on it right it can no longer
hide in the dark for my undergrad
capstone project I did a case study on
this woman this black woman who was in
jail and she was pregnant and she died
in jail because she had an ectopic
pregnancy and they the officers and the
nurses didn't help her the other inmates
were saying like hi like he can you hear
her she's she's like dying and nobody
did anything but in doing my research we
see that those same guards and nurses in
that same jail 15 years earlier looked
the same exact thing happened to another
black woman from the same
that cause when you're saying that to
with the whole like kind of the health
disparities between black and brown
communities like I'm thinking about the
father of gynecology like perfected his
fistula operation on slave women without
anesthetics something that we talked
about a lot in my classes and in my
extracurriculars during my Master's was
that this kind of like general idea that
black children and black women girls in
particular kind of seen as older than
they are and seen as like being able to
withstand pain I think a lot of our
understanding of this comes you know
growing up is obviously in our history
books and now talk about stuff like this
and they kind of paint the whole civil
rights movement us like Oh mark like dr.
King came and he fixed racism Rosa Parks
fix racism and now we're good you know
and kids are kind of growing up and
they're like you know they see these
things happen to like wait but I thought
like racism it's fixed no yeah the first
person to like do the Rosa Parks thing I
guess and not get off the bus was this
young dark-skinned girl who was pregnant
and but they didn't want her to be the
face of the movement there's so many
facets of bias and racism within
communities even not just between
communities my dad he's very
light-skinned and I tried to tell him
one time that colorism is a thing and
lights getting privilege is a thing and
he was like no it's not when I go places
like people were respecting me because
I'm me and that was like okay but he
almost couldn't recognize that if we
were to go someplace we wouldn't get the
same reaction because like me being a
darker skinned black woman and him being
a lighter skinned man like not only is
there the lighter skin privilege but
also to see being a man in a lot of
spaces that holds like a lot of weight I
have also had a few conversations
regarding I guess just like
microaggressions one conversation was
with my supervisor because I experienced
a mic regression at work and he is a
white male he's in his 50s and the first
thing he says is Angela you know I will
never be able to understand your
experience I recognize that I am a white
male but can you help me understand and
I literally broke down when he said that
because it was such a place of humility
you know that he took and I strongly
believe that you know like the person in
the conversation in the room that has
the least power should not be the person
to bring up the hardest topic right and
I think that he created a space where he
recognized that and he kind of lowered
himself to elevate me Hey I love that
story my question for you would also be
like how does your community and I'm I'm
speaking specifically black community
view asian-americans I have personally
seen and experienced a fair amount of
racism from I don't want to say the
Asian community but specific people but
I've also experienced the opposite but I
do think that it in particularly when
traveling abroad it's like something
that I think about a lot just the way
that anti blackness is everywhere and
also like and this is I again I don't
think this is just an an Asian thing I
think a lot of community a lot of non
black communities want to have the
benefits of blackness but none of the
other stuff that comes with it
none of the negative things that come
with it I think that there is a history
of strife between the Asian community
and the black community and I think a
lot of it is design
the model minority that term that model
minority term was created by white
people as a way to pit to perpetuate
anti blackness what the model minority
myth is is when you know basically a
turn about white people have created
saying that Asians you know look how
hard-working they are they are a group
of people that can pull themselves up by
the bootstraps
look how successful they can be in our
society and then kind of pit that
against the black community and be like
why aren't you doing anything if this
group of immigrants right can do this
why can't you to only justify like their
position of Oh like we're not racist
right you're the problem
yeah I think we must understand that how
we've been used in that way like
weaponized you know against the black
community we have this like perpetual
foreigner status right like we are a
model minority until your perpetual
foreigner it's kind of like the idea of
like pet to threat right like we're good
with you until you are like coronavirus
happens and you're a threat like your
Yellow Peril
yeah in kind of the beginning of the
pandemic I guess I had to I had like a
little bit of the heated conversation
with a friend of mine because he had
been in Shanghai for work and when he
came back his co-worker said something
like like I hope you didn't bring
anything back we're gonna have to
separate one of the like Asian American
employees and he told me about it later
and I said okay so what did you say and
he said nothing and I was so upset
because in that moment that person has
enough either of respect for you or has
enough of a relationship with you to
tell a joke like that then it's on you
to use that position to say hey this is
not okay it's just uh
edible at this point to not speak up
about things because especially when the
other person is not in the room to
defend themselves I feel like you can't
choose when to be like anti-racist
because all these issues are connected
and all these issues affect real human
beings how do you think Asian Americans
can show up for black lives in an Asian
American Way which however you perceive
that for a start I would just say like
using our own voice just like speak out
generally and then also recognizing the
privileged that some people have to like
benefit from black culture and blackness
but not have any of the like bad
implications of it and then also like
making space for like when you're
elevated to a certain level like making
space for other people like you and that
level whether you're like a woman in the
boardroom like make room for other women
in those spaces or make room for other
people of color in those spaces I think
is important I think oftentimes the
racial discourse has been under a binary
of black and white and that kind of
renders people in between as feeling
invisible or feeling irrelevant to the
discourse and I think that's why a lot
of people feel like they can't speak up
because it's always about black and
white right and so what would be helpful
is like to even offer space to people
like non black people of color to have
those voices to you know because there
is something unique about their
experiences right that is going to
contribute to a lie [ __ ] just like I
would I might expect like friends of
mine to be allies for the black
community I expect for myself to be an
ally for other communities including
including the asian-american community
including the Hispanic Latin X
communities including any
and everybody I really enjoyed our
conversation Kayla and like you said I
think that we do have a lot in common
and everything that you're saying my
heart was like yes like even though our
experiences are different like that
feeling of like not being seen like is
so like just it's like the theme of our
conversation I um thank you for talking
with me yeah thank you so much for
everything that you shared with me think
it's just something that a really little
treasure thanks
[Music]
I love the discussion around women's
health they really sort of did a deep
dive on women's health in regards to
especially black women in particular and
how our bodies have been used for
centuries within the within the medical
field to test and to prod and pry and
figure things out and specifically from
you know the father the quote unquote
father of gynecology J Marion Sims he
was perfecting his process on black
women's bodies only to you know blow up
and really start this whole sector of
the medical field that hadn't really
been ironed out yet black women are
constantly kicked out of hospitals or
left for dead and neglected because they
are not only not treated as valuable
human beings but their symptoms must be
a that's also gendered because they must
be hysterical because they're women
they're considered to be stronger like
oxen because we're you know born here as
shadows of animals not human beings um
so all that stuff all that bias the
slightest bias well I just thought she
was asymptomatic or I thought that was
probably just indigestion that is that
is fueled by a bias like they're more
they're less reliable people that can't
be true they can't be trusted to know
themselves or others as well they're
less mature or they can handle it yeah
they're stronger y'all y'all are just
that you're the face of undying strength
oh absolutely I mean I can say myself
you know I've heard the term time and
time again in regards to the
asian-american community as being the
model minorities you know that kind of
thing but I just in and it totally makes
sense but I never liked the way that she
articulated it was so eye opening
because she was saying you know that
term was developed by white people in
order to weaponize Asian people to
really separate the marginalized
communities from each other so that we
can't band together and we don't feel
like we are sort of all in this together
there it's really a lot of that
separation it's just like colorism and
slavery white people you know and having
the house slaves in the field slaves you
know really driving that friction
of communities one of the things that
I'm reminded of in this conversation is
when I was studying the Black Panthers I
think in high school and understand
about Japanese and Asian support for the
Black Panthers and the term Yellow Peril
and and seeing an it was called one of
the first examples to me of one minority
standing up for the other we were used
to seeing it around gender or sexual
orientation in this generation men
standing up in the me2 movement and
advocating people advocating against
sexual assault or rape culture or
certainly straight sis culture standing
up and advocating for those in the LGBTQ
community so we're used to the
structures there
but but in the minority community there
tends to be such isolation which is both
its strength and in many ways possibly
its weakness because it creates
separateness yeah and I think you know
it sort of brings us back to the idea of
a life versus appropriation and making
sure that if you are taking and you know
appreciating the cool parts of certain
cultures and like the parts that are
like convenient you know make that that
are fun right but that you're also doing
research and you're also acknowledging
and amplifying the bad that also goes
you know on within those communities and
efforts to change you know you know so I
think it's really just being intentional
I think an example of that Freddie that
is that is work to communicate this idea
to others is you have black woman's hair
styles have been banned made
unprofessional you can't wear them right
basically all the hair styles that any
hair styles that white folks can't do
are considered unprofessional for black
women are various braids dreadlocks
twist bantu knots etc they're just
considered unprofessional just happens
to be primarily black hair expression
but once you start seeing pop culture
icons that are white or not black
wearing cornrows and they rename them as
something else and they're on there on
runways for Chanel and Dior and do-rags
and all these things that we weren't
allowed in your establishment if we had
our hair that way if we I wore Tim boots
if we drink this beer there's all types
of codified racism right an example of
how to be an ally
is once you get in with that hairstyle
advocating that we all get in if you
just walk in and leave them all out in
the cold that's when you're
appropriating that's when you're
actually not down for anything but
yourself beautifully put
well that completes this round of
conversations I think we covered a lot
of ground had people from all over the
country being really personal and having
a really productive conversations I
think there's a lot to break down oh
you're doing it in the comments and
doctor the pre and and we've tried to do
our part by carrying you through some of
these things and sharing our thoughts
insights and experiences yes thank you
so much to all the participants this was
such a valuable experience and hopefully
all the viewers enjoyed it and learned
something as well because I definitely
did yeah it does take some some bravery
I don't know if all of us would have
signed up to go in blind for these
one-on-one conversations sight unseen
and for it to be broadcast around the
world hats off to you all for stepping
up and being brave enough to have some
of these conversations I've taken a lot
from this experience I must say I think
throughout we talked about some of the
commonalities that reared their heads
not necessarily good or bad but in a way
that really helps us kind of understand
exactly why we do exercises like this
any ideas that stuck out stuck out to
you as particularly resonant and where
people showed some growth yeah I mean I
think everyone walked out hopefully and
I really do think based on what we were
able to see I think everyone walked out
of this experiment a little bit more
aware and I think that that is the goal
you know it's not about being perfect
it's not about not having bias we all
have our biases and so I think that it's
really important that you recognize them
and then what really counts is what you
do once you recognize them and how you
sort of affect change in the world and
that's what we've seen so much of in
this last year is folks letting those
biases tumble tumble until they grow so
heavy that they can't be stopped and
people just get out of control I'm glad
that didn't happen any of these
conversations and we could actually have
productive dialogue
really
impressed by the ability of a lot of our
participants to step up to adjust to not
like what they hear but still find a way
to stay on an even keel and have a
productive conversation I'm really happy
we did this and again thanks thanks for
the P&G and BuzzFeed for for creating a
space for it it's a it's pretty damn
smart yes thank you so much and it's
been great chatting with you Jesse and
just getting to know more and really
bounce ideas off of each other I feel
like it was I mean I listen I can't
think of a better pairing yeah yeah one
of the main goals for today's experiment
and conversation is for you to walk away
with some more confidence some more
tools more courage to have similar
conversations about bias with the folks
around you we've also created a resource
guide for how to best have these
conversations and can't stress this
enough a productive manner all right
the only point is not just an exercise
in getting your bars off and it's about
actually how can you move the ball
forward and it's not always the person I
would say that you're talking to with
the others that are listening as well so
we've partnered with a few organizations
that are leading the charge in this
department and work with them to
developed a detailed plan to help in the
best ways that we can some of that
includes learning about historical and
present-day experiences the fuel
systemic racism that fuel inequality
ways that you where you live whatever
that is you can activate your local
communities directly you can be an ally
and advocated activists you can
certainly be anti-racist we've talked
before and the choice that P&G put
together really does a good job of
illustrating that yeah you can't be
neutral on a moving train as Howard Zinn
used to say you have to be anti-racist
donate to these organizations that we've
laid out that advance equity and justice
there are people that are really
spending their time and energy on
unjustice for folks they need our
support and they need our money
obviously also and we can't stress that
enough all it takes is in life these
little pivot points where you exposed to
something that you otherwise wouldn't
and it might inform a lot of decisions
going forward so should go ahead and
share the video you could have some
really interesting conversations
anyway for yourself but for others so go
ahead and click the link on the video
description for a page with more details
and how to learn how to activate and
donate Freddie I think we came we saw we
learned I'm really pleasantly surprised
I didn't know how this was gonna go I
was excited about it but I'm I'm proud
of what of what we not only learned an
experience but shared with each other
today so I want to thank you for your
time energy and expertise really made a
world of difference yes thank you so
much I honestly I mean I love talking
about this stuff I could talk about it
all day so this is not work for me it's
definitely something that is more more
than that for me so I'm happy to be a
part of this whole experiment and
project as a whole and to everyone
watching thank you so much for watching
and stay safe stay loud and feel changed
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]